we are meeting here today
at a place which symbolizes three
true european stories first
indeed the european vaccination campaign
that is picking up speed right now
second europe is leading worldwide on
revolutionary
life-saving mrna and third in the midst
of an
unprecedented health crisis europe is
the global vaccine champion
making vaccines available to the rest of
the world
this week we pass the mark
of 150 million doses delivered
in terms of deployment we have already
passed
123 million vaccinations
and with the enormous efforts of
biontech pfizer and the acceleration of
their vaccine deliveries
i'm now confident that we will have
sufficient doses
to vaccinate 70 of the
adult population in the european union
already
in july this manufacturing site
was the first to produce an mrna vaccine
at large
scale in europe a ground-breaking
innovation
and this pioneering technology could be
the backbone
of our future vaccine portfolio
europe is producing vaccines for
europeans
and for citizens around the world
we have exported more than 155
million doses of vaccine to over 87
countries worldwide since december
we are the pharmacy of the world and we
europeans take pride in this
and we invite others to join because we
all know
nobody will be safe until everybody is
safe
you